time for new rule
white people white people have to admit
that they've thought about burning down
a cbs2 the size of airplane hangars
there's always just one employee and
she's busy developing photos for the one
person left in the world who still uses
film new roll the winner of Saturday
nights may whether Pacquiao fight has to
take on Baltimore slot bomb and the
winner of that has to fight Chuck
Knight's car
no if you're so anti-gay that you not
only demonstrated in front of the
Supreme Court building this week but
also did a Google image search for gay
men kissing click through a bunch of
pages to find the one you wanted no not
that one
now that's the Pope a warmer now to warm
up perfect yes that's the one come on
there's easier ways to tell the world
you're gay new rule we don't need a
female version of hooters
oh yes introducing tallywackers the nude
chain restaurant where women can live
out their wildest fantasy chicken wings
with this side of beefcake I don't see
the allure and I'm guessing my female
friends don't either but hey at least
this guy will have somewhere to eat
after the anti-gay marriage rally
numeral someone has to tell the widows
who are buying the new dildo that has a
mini urn inside to hold your departed
husband's ashes that you're supposed to
hold a piece of him in your heart
by the way this model here also vibrates
and has three speeds slow medium and if
you could have done this when you were
alive I wouldn't have poison you
you